[Music]
Eastern Caribbean the island of
Montserrat this tiny island is one of
the last remaining outposts of the
British Empire it measures just sixteen
point five kilometers long by 10 wide
almost the size of the city of Dublin
it's a haven for the rich and famous and
home to err recording studios used by
rock and pop stars the island is
celebrated for its natural beauty and
tranquil easygoing lifestyle 80% of the
island's infrastructure lies in the
shadow of sue free air hills a mountain
lying 915 metres above sea level that
dominates the southern half of the
island most of the population of ten and
a half thousand live and work in the
capital Plymouth or farm the rich
fertile soil on the mountain slopes
[Music]
on the northern flank like the village
of Farrell's yard home - Delia pond it
is a paradise and because everybody is
so friendly towards one another we never
have a cave in the world I guess we have
brought up in a way to accept life for
what it is Delia has lived in Montserrat
her entire life and is a mother with six
children she rents a small holding where
she grows vegetables to sell on the
neighboring islands David Lee is an
American missionary who has lived on
Montserrat for 15 years he's also a keen
amateur cameraman and has filmed
everything from carnivals to local
sporting events it's off the beaten path
it's the way the Caribbean used to be
the people are genuinely friendly and we
came for a month and checked it out and
it was just like they said and we never
left but beneath this tropical Garden of
Eden lies a hidden menace
the lush vegetation and productive soil
belies a lethal reality the island is
volcanic Montserrat sits directly on a
geological subduction zone this is one
of the most seismically active parts of
the planet's crust
the North Atlantic tectonic plate moving
westward sinks beneath the Caribbean
plate as it descends it melts forming
magma which over millennia finds its way
to the Earth's surface creating a string
of volcanic islands known as the Lesser
Antilles
but Montserrat has shown no signs of
major volcanic activity for
approximately 370 years the only
evidence of Vulcan isset e-r Springs hot
enough to boil an egg sprouting from the
slopes of SU Freire Hills then on the
18th of July 1995
everything changes
the Islanders hear a deafening noise
similar to the sound of a jet engine
coming from the mountain